foreign
we did a Valentine's week last week that
was about relationships and marriage and
sex intimacy all that
and some of the calls that we got during
sex and intimacy and relationship week
for Valentine's Day we had Hearts like
flying around on the screen behind us
some of the calls got really heavy they
were hard calls but they were very
important calls and so we didn't end up
using them in the Valentine's episodes
because we were going for a very
specific ethos right a very specific
tone
but I also didn't want to lose the call
I didn't want to lose the moment that I
was able to share that somebody honored
me with sharing with them and
um
man a couple of these calls
we get questions about this stuff all
the time so they're going to help a
whole lot of folks so this is one of
those calls you're gonna see like I said
you're gonna see hearts flying around
it's gonna be like what is happening I'm
wearing different shirt right if you're
watching this whole episode if you're
listening to it you won't know any
different but
um I really thought this was an
important call so I want you to check
this out
let's go to Ryan in Phoenix Arizona
what's up Ryan
hey how are you thanks for taking my
call today you got it man what's up
so let me give you a little back story
here
um
been married for almost 14 years got
married kind of young at 22.
um so it's just kind of the culture of
where we grew up and religion and the
expectation is you get married young you
start having kids right
and I tried calling off the engagement
and didn't feel like it was right still
wanted to date more
and was convinced partially that maybe
it was just anxiety that I should still
go through with it that led up to kind
of the wedding day
and even at the altar you know where
we're getting married I wanted to say no
I knew that it wasn't right
and so you know with these thoughts and
these feelings so I've been struggling
with
feelings of regret
um second guessing pretty much our
entire marriage which has led to kind of
one foot in one foot out
um never really fully committed a
hundred percent and
recently led to a I I feel like this
kind of led to a recent Affair that I
had
um and so I'm really struggling right
now with this thought process do I stay
do I go
she wants to make this work
um
why would she want to be married to
somebody who has resented her for 15
years 14 years
that is a very good question I don't
know and I've asked her that
so I
why is she the wrong person
and I want you to articulate it very
specifically and don't BS me like why is
she the wrong person
I've always been attracted to other
women more than her okay so say that in
a way that is not a circling passive
aggressive way you're not attracted to
your wife
um I don't know how to word that
just yes or no man
yeah yeah yeah that's what it comes down
to okay
um what about her do you not find
attractive
um
she was just no or hasn't ever really
just been my
type if that's even a thing and
I I struggle staying this out loud I
know that's why that's why I'm asking
you to do it because I wanna I want to
get out of you live your whole existence
is in your feelings
sure and it's the articulation of some
of these things that really turns the
lights on to the feelings
because feelings are are terrible GPS
directors they're fantastic indicators
of wreck car wreck ahead you need to
exit here but they're terrible
um forgiving directions
and your whole life is run by feelings
that's why I'm pushing you I want you to
articulate very specifically
because let's I'll just throw something
out there okay and I know I'm making it
uncomfortable I know it's hard what I'm
asking you to do yeah um let's say your
wife is uh you don't find her pretty
because you think she's overweight
and you have always been attracted to
someone who um is not overweight or in
your mind isn't overweight and
you fixate on her weight and you lean in
on hey what about this or what if we ate
like this and what if we did this or
whatever or there's some physical
feature of hers it's just not like I
just think other people are whatever
that is
feeling after feeling after feeling
after feeling after feeling
and so I want you to own here's a big
shift you've got to make
you you're talking with what I call
distance language this led to this which
led to this which led to me having an
affair I call bullcrap on that
you did have somebody that you felt all
along I shouldn't be marrying I
shouldn't be marrying and you married
them that happens that happens yeah and
then every day for 14 years you've
chosen to be miserable
that is a conscious daily choice you
have made
you consciously chose to sleep with
somebody that wasn't your wife nothing
led to another thing you chose that and
I want you the reason I'm saying that
directly I want you to own it because
that's the only way you can then take
ownership of what happens next
because you're going to be the guy
that's like is gonna slowly Drown Your
Wife until she finally gets the courage
to leave you because you haven't had the
courage to you see what I'm saying
yeah or the courage to say
after 14 years I've been lying to you I
actually am not attracted to you in this
way or I I think you're beautiful and I
think you're wonderful I'm actually
attracted to her too or her also or to
other women too right does that make
sense it's so yeah there's something
about saying things out loud and
truthful even when they hurt and are
awful and make you sound like a complete
and total ass which I think you can be
right so it's all of that and together
but you're living in this mushy emotive
feeling world and usually if you listen
to the show I'm having to take big tough
guys and get them to sit in the
emotional feeling world you're the
opposite man you got to get up and face
reality
yeah that makes sense
yeah yeah and so okay so you you let's
let's I I don't think it's true but
let's let's go with it I'm gonna trust
you you made a mistake getting married
right yeah and you're married
why have you chosen misery for 14 years
good question I feel
there you go I don't care about your
feelings why have you chosen misery
I am a people pleaser at heart excellent
and I don't like ruffling feathers and I
do that to the detriment of myself
you do that to the detriment of your
kids and to the detriment of your wife
yes and your faith community does that
make sense
yeah
um
can you think back to moments when y'all
were in sync and connected
yeah I I think back and I I've thought
about this my entire marriage hasn't
been a complete sham I've been
happy we've had happy moments
um
and I I have a hard time sparsing out
what was different then
versus now knowing that I've always had
these underlying thoughts and regrets
Isaac gonna sound so crazy but I don't
think you have
hmm
um as the great brene Brown says what
you go looking for you're sure to find
sure tell me about this affair where'd
you meet this person
work yeah and how was it
exciting yeah honestly it was exciting
and
it fulfilled
desires that I've had for a long time
okay about being with somebody that I
was more attracted to
what was beneath that attraction
what do you mean
tell me if I'm off
you've been being told what to do your
whole freaking life
yeah and you've been writing through
life on other people's train tracks your
entire life
yeah and somebody else essentially
picked out your wife for you somebody
picked up the life for you they picked
out your church they picked up the
building they picked out the little
white picket fence around the house you
were gonna live in
somebody else picked out the clothes
that your kids are going to wear they
picked out the schools are going to go
to everybody's picked out your life for
you
and I think you have taken all of that
frustration in really what it is it's
rage
and you've put that on your wife
and then somebody comes along and yes
beautiful beautiful co-workers sexy
co-worker laughs at your jokes all those
things
maybe does things in bed that your wife
won't do like all that stuff
but beneath that
is somebody looking you in the eye and
saying you're freaking Ryan you can do
anything
and for the first time in 14 years
probably 30 years you felt alive
am I right or wrong
no you're right and are you still with
that person
with the affair
no
did the air run out of that real quick
um I actually change the jobs okay
um
but
if I'm being honest I would love to go
back okay
um
have you given up on your marriage and
that's a that's a question you've got to
answer honestly because if you're out of
your marriage dude have the courage to
stop dragging your wife behind a moving
car it's cruel man
I agree I agree
and that's that's where I have these
huge
conflicting arguments in my brain every
single day it's a real real simple
argument it is there's not conflicting
back and forth I am going to never call
that woman again yes she's sexy yes
she's beautiful yes we had a wild fun
time and I felt alive
but it was cancer
I am gonna never call her again when she
when pictures of her naked body pop in
my mind or things we were doing together
when that pops my mind I'm gonna
intentionally choose to not think about
I'm gonna have another thought ready to
go
and I will double down every inch of my
every second of my life will be
committed to my wife moving forward
we're gonna make this thing work
it's that
or it's I'm out
and both of them take bravery and you
haven't displayed that yet
no
no because I'm afraid to yeah and you
should be and I'm gonna tell you this
one thousand percent
and the people in the YouTube comments
bro don't read them because they're
going to be mean to you or they're going
to be like you just live your own life
YOLO or whatever
right what's gonna happen is you're
gonna go leave your wife move into an
apartment you got kids too
three okay you're gonna leave your three
kids you're gonna leave your wife and
you're gonna move into apartment
and you're gonna have that Hollow
feeling but this other girl is gonna
come over for a season
and then you're gonna realize One Day
You're Gonna Roll over when she spends
the night
and you're gonna catch a glimpse of
yourself in the mirror and you're gonna
realize you went with you to that new
bed
yeah and you don't like Ryan you never
have
yeah
and so you're trapped trying to get
somebody else to make you feel worthy
and you found somebody at work man you
found somebody that made you feel
valuable and alive and excited all those
things
I believe with all my guts any couple
any couple can reclaim that in their
marriage if they both decide to and make
no mistake your wife's gonna participate
in this too
yeah right but she can't participate in
something that you haven't been honest
about
or that you him hard about or you've
been like man I just can we like spice
some things up and she's like I I don't
really know what that means you're like
well you know I need you to do these
things so that I feel alive
yeah or this particular sex act makes me
feel alive or we go away for the weekend
or when you do this with the kids it
makes me feel dead inside can we try
something else
and that starts with you being brave not
blaming her for not doing stuff does
that make sense
yeah yeah that makes sense
so what are you gonna do
I don't know
and that's honestly that's where I'm
struggling the most is knowing what to
do she wants to make it work does she
know you cheated on her she knows yeah
where you've been in counseling and
therapy
um
she would not still be wanting to make
it work if you've been honest in therapy
and you haven't been
okay have you
no I I feel like I have been
yeah you've told her you're not
attracted to her and why
I I have told her all of the reasons
um and she still wants to make this work
and so you know I'm filled with guilt
I'm filled with shame I'm filled with
regret and
you know making one decision one way or
the other I'm afraid that if I make a
decision will I continue to regret and
then have even more regret on top of
regret if I make the wrong decision
and so we're we've been stuck in this
holding pattern of going to therapy and
talking and her knowing that I'm still
on the fence of not sure what to do and
it's cruel
um yeah I agree I I feel like I am
holding her hostage you're holding
yourself hostage
[Music]
um
yeah you
here's what I here's what I think you
tell me I'm crazy
I think you love this woman that you're
married to
and I think like all marriages she's not
perfect and you're not either
and I think you think so little of
yourself
and saying your needs out loud and
saying dreams of yours out loud and
going and actually getting out of your
own freaking head and doing doing acting
making moves in your life in your career
as a dad as a husband as a lover like
getting after it instead of just sitting
there and stewing in these
and these loop-de-loopy loopty Loops man
and I think you've cast all of your
feelings of depression all your feelings
of sadness and of well you know life
you've dumped all of that on your wife
because you were unsure of the marriage
in the first place I believe you on that
you're unsure of it perhaps 100
absolutely 100
but I think the question you've got to
ask yourself is
what choice am I going to make moving
forward and
dude
you can't just sit there stood up man
you got to make a call because you're
drowning you're teaching your kids this
is what love looks like this is what a a
wife this is how you this is how you
value and love her
this is what being a decisive dad looks
like a co-parent and a co-creator of a
home looks like man they're worth more
than that you are too
I think though until you decide that
you're worth being well and you get
whole you're going to continue on this
loop-de-loop man and I promise you
you're gonna if you leave your wife and
go to this other person you're gonna
it's gonna be several months
before either she leaves you and you get
into one of these Loop tube I don't know
what we want for dinner and I don't I'm
just gonna start looping on you or
um
you're gonna realize oh crap I went with
me
I hate that you're in this position man
um it's it's it's you've got to start
taking ownership right now
right now
here's the choices I've made up to now
I've chosen misery I've chosen
dishonesty I've chosen infidelity and
you can also choose
to completely hit control or delete and
become a different person you can choose
that today
or you can choose to be the guy that
left his wife and kids for the woman to
work you could choose that too
God's sakes Mega Choice man
stop dragging your family through it